[Music]
seal the conquest to seal the
victory that the Islamic jihadists
believe that they won by mass murdering
Americans on September 11th
2001 that triumphal mosque if built will
be understood by Muslims around the
world in exactly the same way that they
understand all the other triumphal
mosques around the
world there is no way that a couple of
imams in New York City are going to be
able even if they were sincere which you
will see in the film is Highly
Questionable but even if they were
sincere they will not be able to
convince the vast majority of Muslims
around the world that this is a whole
new kind of mosque that's built to do
something nice to infidels instead of
something evil to them it's never
happened before it's not happening now
we cannot let this mosque be built
because if this mosque is built it will
be the single most encouraging thing on
the planet for Islamic
jihadists and they will come at us like
they've never come at us
before so this film
Chronicles the story of the mosque
construction the resistance to the
mosque
where everything stands now and what we
must do thank you again for coming and
now the director of the film Pamela
[Applause]
Geller thank you so much for coming um
those of you that were here yesterday
the hundreds that came um so many young
people which was so encouraging because
I cannot tell you how many of those
young people came over to me and said oh
my God I had no idea I there was so much
that I didn't know and in making this
film it was very very difficult to make
it is difficult to watch I'm warning you
the beginning is very
graphic and the reason why I included
that is because there's been an embargo
on these images you notice you'll never
see images of
911 uh nobody talks about 911 on 911 the
pictures are dusted off The Telecast are
rebroadcast for a limited amount of time
and then it gets put back in the
Box uh when I did a bus campaign as I
said
yesterday and I couldn't run it because
I was using an image of the the attack
the historical record of photograph I
could not use because it was deemed
offensive uh but a 15 story mosque
looking down in a building that was
destroyed by the landing gear of the
planes that's somehow not
offensive it is outrageous it is
deliberately provocative and it's
contemptuous how they talk to us and the
reason why I made this film was the
historical record of this fight must be
documented history must must show that
there was fierce opposition and not only
Fierce opposition but how the story
arked how it was ignored first Herald
first it was heralded by the New York
Times and then ignored and by virtue by
the power of the people that came out to
our rallies tens of thousands and even
then the media ignored it and that story
became viral
on the net people sent it to their email
lists the photographs of the June 6th
rally and then the media had no choice
but to cover
it and when they they don't cover it
they shape it they shape the story and
you see how they
demonize the opposition but worse the
9/11 families who took the hit for all
of us because we were all we were all a
Target they are victimized
again I have to thank they're not here
uh all the 9/11 families uh the seven
who spoke yesterday they got on a train
they came down here they got here at
2:00 and they got back on a train at
6:30 because they couldn't get Char here
they wanted to stay over they couldn't
stay over I want to thank Eileen Walsh
who lost her firefighter son she's in
the audience she won't be able to stay
for the whole thing her daughter
Patricia lost her brother Nelly binsky
lost her son
this movie will show you how the ground
zero mosque came onto the national
landscape how everybody who was fighting
the mosque was demonized and I want you
to understand the context of how and why
this happens the media is self-censoring
they are enforcing uh Islamic law
Islamic law says you cannot insult or
defame Islam even if it's true
my friend ha Builders or in America G
Wilders yes he deserves Applause he's in
this film he spoke he came in he came in
he flew in and spoke on the September
11th rally and flew right out that's how
critical he understands this fight to be
he's on trial for hate speech now if
you've seen his movie fit now you know
there's nothing incorrect uh it's a
small documentary on Islamic Islamic
Terror
and the Dutch Criminal Court said it
doesn't matter if what you're saying is
the truth what matters is that it's
illegal and that is the Sharia that is
Islamic law and in Muslim countries if
you insult or defame Islam it's
blasphemy and they kill you anybody who
reads the news not in the mainstream
media but online see the Christians that
are being executed in Muslim countries
for blasphemy law one was it a doctor
was just charged for blasphemy because
he threw out the business card of a man
whose name was
Muhammad yeah now yes you see that
Muslims are using it to to you know uh
get back at whatever non-muslim they
like but here in the west you're not
you're not assassinated but your
character is assassinated you are
marginalized you are destroyed your
reputation you're rended toxic and
people that come to me I have
organizations that come to me see
secretly like like listen we're not
going to say your name and I say it's
okay it's okay to strategize um but I
said remember as soon as you take this
position you are a pamel gell no matter
what's in your heart you are a racist
islamophobic anti-muslim
bigot we have to fight this we must
fight this we must speak you must not
back down do not think that just because
they have the right to build it that
they're going to build it we have been
very very successful they have gotten
nowhere Imam Ru has been exposed for the
deceitful extremist that he is which he
is and they're silver tonged they are
the very best Daisy Khan or Daisy y Khan
extraordinary Liars extraordinary but he
was removed still on the board and even
more contempt is Daisy Khan is on the
board of the 9/11 Memorial and
Museum I mean this Galls the 9/11 family
members who as you heard Rosaline I mean
I I know Rosaline a long time but I had
never heard anybody read the contents of
the autopsy report that was
devastating because if you hear what
they received of their brother of her
brother and and son and then to say that
that's not Ground Zero it's another it's
a it's it's another attack it's like
when someone's having a stroke they keep
inarching
that was the 911 was the opening set so
understand what I'm doing in this film
is I'm showing you how the story how the
story moves how the media the story arc
how they've completely named Sharie
aamal the NBC person of the
year why man was a waiter where he got
the $4.5 million to buy the building is
from alisan right very shady very shady
Medicaid for Brad he defaulted on not
one but two bank loans at $100,000 a
piece and what did he do he made America
Sick by putting in a ground Zer mosque
and he gets NBC person of the year and
and Imam FIS R is nominated for Time
Magazine Man of the Year who extols the
work of shake kada a virent a Jew hater
a virent anti-am
hater is that who he's going to come to
speak at the Islamic Center I ask
you one of the family members said
yesterday no matter what Imam they get
they will be radical because the whole
idea is
radical so I don't want I'm not going to
I'm not going to keep you we'll take
questions after there are some 911
family members I I have to tell you I if
they had known that we it was going to
be panel because I have to thank uh
citizens united yes please a round of
applause for Citizens
United
thank they wrote me they wrote me and
they gave me this okay so I didn't
promote it I I'm I'm thrilled to see
that you're here thank you thank you so
much I mean we were up against Ron Paul
yesterday we had a full house that's
pretty good
itif my event the one fall line was six
feet deep okay I think we should start
the
[Applause]
film